le méga projet d'agrandissement de
l'aéroport de barcelone est tombé à
l'eau un chantier dont les
investissements s'est élevé à plus d'un
milliard d'euros suspendus pour
l'instant à cause des dégâts
environnementaux mais aussi de tensions
politiques ont fait le point avec quelle
entier de laurent à barcelone c'était un
coup de théâtre le gouvernement espagnol
a annoncé qu'il suspendait les
investissements pour l'agrandissement de
l'aéroport de barcelone cela fait plus
de deux mois que le projet est sur la
table d'un côté il y a le gouvernement
espagnol qui est à l'origine du projet
et qu'ils souhaitaient et bien
construire un nouveau terminal à
l'aéroport de barcelone de l'autre côté
il y à la mairie de la ville et mais
aussi les associations écologistes et
puis les habitants de la zone qui
devrait être construite pour il s'agit
d'un espace naturel protégé et il est
donc hors de question d'y construire une
nouvelle piste est entre les deux eh
bien il ya le gouvernement catalan qui
avait accepté le projet d'agrandissement
mais sans grande motivation pour
l'instant et bien tout semble est actée
et pourtant cette semaine et bien la
situation a pris un autre tournant les
détails de l'agrandissement ont été
annoncés et avec eux et bien les
possibles dommages écologiques ce qui a
poussé le gouvernement catalan à se
retirer du projet en réponse est bien le
gouvernement espagnol a annoncé qu'il
retirait ses investissements et ce pour
au moins cinq ans c'est donc un projet
reporté au moins pour l'instant pour les
associations écologistes c'est une
première victoire mais ce n'est pas la
fin du combat je me propose de découpe
et dany pardo le porte parole de l'une
de ces associations ont l'impression
qu'ils ces quelques poids que par un
bras de fer de la part du gouvernement
de madrid et du coup on rester très
attentif on continue d'appeler à la
gronder
manifestation du dimanche 19 septembre
qu'on pensera historique ce projet
d'agrandissement de l'aéroport n'est pas
seulement rejeté par les écologistes il
fait aussi débat parmi les habitants de
la zone qui redoute des nuisances
sonores et puis également auprès de
certains barcelonais qui craignent une
augmentation du tourisme à barcelone et
que la fin